good morning John I'm making an album is
terrible sound in here fix this
that's better good morning John I'm
making an album sometimes John you have
to make sacrifices and today I'm
sacrificing good video for good audio I
wouldn't be doing that if I wasn't
talking about my album but I want you to
know that I'm dedicated to making things
sound good maybe I can bump the ISO up a
little bit now I need to fix the white
balance as good as we're gonna get so
how am I gonna make an album well with
some of my favorite musicians from the
world including the guy who films edits
and directs crash course chemistry Nick
Jenkins Rob Scallon of the Rob skeleton
YouTube channel
[Music]
Yoda George of Harry and the Potters and
Andrew Wong of songs to wear pants too
let's let them introduce themselves my
name is Andrew Huang and my channel is
songs to wear pants do wear many musical
adventures take place you know claims
doping days old I picked up boys dancing
I'm waiting for what I weirdest type of
music you've ever made someone told me
to make a sexy song about airplane
terminology who are you I'm Joe joy
[Music]
yeah or up like a Chancellor it's a
democratic state I'm not scaling and I
play guitar a lot I rule a Pisa
so the pyramids are mine do you feel
about slavery there ah obviously heavily
bro what about you the car dealer no no
no you would actually know the world's
fastest clapper I really do we have one
YouTube video that's on my second
channel can I get a cut footage for to
it here yeah yeah that makes me
interested what
super weird skill do you have comments i
make a video montage of all the weirdest
skills what's your weirdest feel no one
else in the world can do this I can flip
my eyelids up wait what well you see the
difference between this and and this yes
oh yeah right oh I can oh wow can do
this this one's for the lady
so what weird thinking you do I think
this would be an amazing collab video
for all of us in the world just a purse
is visible
you
[Music]
going really well so far they're really
talented I'm really not gonna be able to
work with them some songs you've heard
some songs you haven't we're gonna be
covering some zones it's pretty cool I
kind of have a band right now it was
I've never had before all right Thank
You mr. Tao for improving my sound
quality of making the video super weird
and thanks to Nick and Andrew and Joe
and Robb for making music with me John
I'll see you on Tuesday
and yes this is the last day of the 12
days of pizza mess so go buy your pizza
things now they will never be available
again except maybe the like number one
top-selling thing I'm not sure